bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs avec éloi
roland jouvent soirée loi bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir à tous édition spéciale
champion du monde et nous avons invité
exceptionnel ont évité bac de retour oui
il revient il revient il s'agit de
l'ancien propriétaire de la rubrique à
josé et donc puisqu'il s'appelle josé il
s'agit de josé de sousa qui nous vient
tout droit de la fac d'économie de paris
et du portugal accessoirement bonsoir on
rappelle que tu as été champion du
portugal junior il est bien entendu il
ya de ça quelques années donc tu es un
joueur d'échecs de international tel un
héros de combien en fait deux
292 voix là d'un [ __ ] un petit vélo en
fait un petit théo c'est pas un petit et
lourd puisque c'est quand même y'a pas
beaucoup d'adhérence il y en a combien
centaines de sang je ne sais pas je
connais pas les chiffres exacts
cependant on peut dire que josé s'occupe
du club de paris nice a activement en ce
moment donc c'est un club qui est en
nationale 2 c'est ça et vous allez
remonter en national espérons alors
championnat du monde
évidemment résultat on va pas vous faire
attendre plus longtemps avec les
familles gros match un homme adams et
cherokee tout cas alors que s'est il
passé
alors effectivement dans une très très
belle affiche notamment pour le match
adams annoncé deux favoris qui se
rencontre extrêmement difficile à
prédire à nos textes de joueurs
extrêmement solide qui perdent très peu
de parties le résultat on va pas vous le
cacher à nantes a gagné 2 est ni un
ennemi il a gagné la deuxième partie
ensuite adams n'a rien pu faire tout
simplement que des donc sur quatre
parties trois nuls et une victoire pour
annan ça suffit pour se qualifier
notez qu'il aura pas eu de départage
dans ces deux demi finales puisque josé
l'autre demi finale a été gagnée par
shirov et on va dire de façon curieuse
oui en tout cas plus joli que le match
menant de dams qui était vraiment
ennuyeux disons plutôt un match très
technique
en tout cas donc pas forcément très
accessible pas forcément très sportif
mais en tout cas un match bâle alors
simplement très technique qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans ce match et rob higgitt
yucatan bah disons que c'était deux
joueurs
très talentueux puis très créatif donc
ça fait deux très jolies parties
c'est amusant à regarder moi j'ai
regardé en direct je trouvais ça amusant
revanche à nantes adams était plus plus
technique lui proposer le résultat le
résultat deux ennemis un ennemi pour
gris pour rire mais là cette fois par
contre avec des victoires oui c'est ça
deux victoires pour shirov une victoire
progrès de chocques une nulle très beau
match et rohff très sportif créé tout
cas bien bien été à la hauteur
donc une première partie explosive c'est
celle qu'on va commenter ce soir - le
deuxième tir aux gagnants dont
l'ouverture est ensuite gaffe fait une
gaffe qui lui coûte la partie donc parce
qu'on y joue quelqu'un de la révélation
de ce tournoi qui n'a que 17 ans
personne ne l'attendait ici on commence
à se dire est-ce qu'il n'a pas une
chance de se qualifier face à shirov et
de devenir le plus jeune champion du
monde de l'histoire parce que il ya 17
ans il avait à 17 ans a savouré était
tout à fait exceptionnel en tout cas le
plus jeune fils était on pensait qu'il
pouvait revenir mais là je suis refais
la somme dans la troisième avec une
nouvelle victoire et dans la quatrième
il a eu des petites chances reach mais
n'a pas su les saisir précisément donc
nul dans cette dernière partie
aucun match départage les deux joueurs
vont être tout frais et dispos pour la
finale il s'agit donc d'une très belle
finale schirrhoffen andes ouais c'est ce
qu'on avait eue c'est quasiment ce qu'on
pouvait attendre en fait cette wii c'est
ce qui était prévisible d'après le
d'après le classement et lourde entre
autres en ce moment et si on enlève
morose et mitch c'est une finale qu'on
n'aurait pu prévoir
c'est également les deux joueurs qui
s'étaient rencontrés aux jeux olympiques
oui oui pour la première fois à sydney
dès la fia qui était présent et anne on
avait joué contre chir en fait avait
suivi ce match me this way est un petit
peu mais pas beaucoup mais je crois
qu'ils ont fait que je ne connais pas
assez rapide
ils ont fait 2 2 semi rapides obtenu le
nul non c'était pas très folichon mais
alors là a noté bon enfin on commentera
cette finale en fin d'émission
stéphane ça va être ça va être très très
très très belle fille mais on va revenir
sur cette finale à nantes shirov tu vas
jouer à téhéran à noter que les dents
que les joueurs d'aeon des jours de
repos puisque ça prend ça démarre que
mercredi prochain
oui tout à fait alors on va revoir
maintenant on va voir cette partie
première partie entre cherokee grille
tout c'était un match en quatre parties
shirov redémarre avec les blancs c'est
important de demeurer avec les blancs
probablement un match oui non alors oui
et non ça des pour et des contres
puisque si on commence avec les blancs
et bien on finira avec les noirs ouais
donc dans la dernière partie si notre
adversaire obligé de gagner avec les
blancs il ya des chances de pouvoir
arriver à quelque chose
alors qu'on l'a vu adams contre allende
adams avait les noirs dans la dernière
partie est arrivée n'a rien pu faire
tout simplement
donc la gauche heroes fait les blondes
on peut tout de suite imposé son style
imposé son jeu
over puissant alors allons-y bauer
spectaculaire je veux très
impressionnant avec ses shirov de 4
l'instant c'est pas très impressionnant
mais ça va le devenir
le cinq cavaliers f3 et c6 papa de
défense russe demain soir les
spectateurs un bon voire le spectateur
effectivement la défense russe c'est
quand on joue l'autre cavaliers et ça
donne des position symétrique qui sont
ils sont beaucoup plus enfin vous
compliqués à devenir explosive de
manière explosive dayan qui ont tendance
à devenir on se rappelle on l'avait
commentée en diagonale le blitz
kalichman contre les co ouais le bliss
que khalifa n'a gagné c'était une
défense russe était une défense russe
mais c'est à nîmes complètement
spectaculaire et très impressionnant fou
mais 5 alors là c'est la partie
espagnole
voilà oui et alors on retrouve la
défense de kramnik quasiment ouais ça
veut dire si ça ressemble à une
berlinoise ça ressemble à une berlinoise
la crise paref avait joué les petit rock
oui c'est ce qui se passe et la
déviation par contre oui puisque là
évidemment le coup de crâne nick enfin
le coût de la défense berlinoise ses
cavaliers plantureux 4 ici greccio
choisi de jouer le coup fous ses cinq co
assez logiquement finalement puisqu'on
dit qu'il faut sortir ces pièces qu'il
faut contrôler centre donc on met le
faux sur une belle case et 4 c 5 qui
contrôle la case des 4 4 centrales
donc pour l'instant à priori un coup qui
a l'air plutôt pas mal et l'assurance
tout de suite tout de suite boom
commence ça fait une place
alors bon shirov on sait qu'il a
l'esprit un peu rebelle un peu une envie
de faire des sacrifices mais normalement
il fait quelque chose de beaucoup plus
spectaculaire c'est qu'il met ses pièces
emprise or là là par contre non il n'est
pas animé sans pièces sata sont prises
mais il a pris une pièce
enfin bref tout ça pour dire qu'il a
joué quelques mots 5 donner une pièce de
façon apparente puisque il ya cavaliers
feront cavalier qui est possible ça n'a
pas été géré par duke mais alors on va
montrer ce qui se passera après quatre
ans qui a gagné
simplement et bien les blancs prennent
le centre complètement en jouant le coût
des deux et quatre des cartes ces
attaques le fou et lecavalier
voilà le pion des dons qu'ils vont
récupérer leurs pièces avec un avantage
de développement et bisons vers les leur
fout de ses hommes notamment qui va
pouvoir sortir où il a noté que la
position stéphanie si bien entendu assez
équilibré oui c'est pas encore terminée
il faut pas il faut pas non plus
dramatiser
cependant les blancs auraient eu
vraisemblablement un léger avantage mais
sans plus mais ça se joue en fait c'est
curieux un sacrifice de pièces comme ça
bon c'est à ces thématiques tout de
suite mais surtout quand on dit souvent
de ne pas jouer deux fois le cavalier
dans 90 des bureaux il joue deux fois la
même pièce et imprécis la sacrifie donc
mais c'est fear of clavier pour leucate
alors là c'est tout dorla bon c'est joli
parce que l'on voit que les joueurs
n'ont pas bougé leurs pions mais qui
n'ont bougé que les pièces
c'est à dire c'est sympathique de pièces
blanches et trois pièces noires qui se
balade en plein centre de l'échiquier
à noter que les blonds une petite
initiative pourquoi il n'y a pas ce
qu'ils ont déjà ok donc ils ont un
avantage de ton que les noirs le roi
noir est encore au centre qui prend le 4
dames deux dames 2 pas mal 1 s'est
classée théorique tout sera sûrement
bien sûr donc d'un jeu des attaques
lecavalier est alors le coup qu'il
faudrait pas faire on va le montrer
quand même ses cavaliers des six par
exemple sortir le cavalier seul piège
classique
ok des six ça serait une respiration une
faute puisque les noirs pourrait jouer
dans cette position et blanc les blancs
pourra jouer cavalier font cavalier car
il rejoint kamali dernier celle qui a
l'air anodin mais qui fait quand même
échec qui fait échec ne viendra très
grave puisque le cavalier t on aux 5
on l'a enlevé ça c'est donc un échec
qu'on appelle à la découverte gagné une
pièce et la partie puisqu'on a récupéré
la dame noire on va prendre la table
effectivement donc c'est tout simplement
terminé
la faute à ne pas faire effectivement il
faut pas bouger ce cahier de la case aux
quatre coins du cou raide choc
maintenant prend 1,5
maintenant maintenant hélas alors chez
elle pour y reprendre tout de suite mais
il joue un coup
encore plus dynamique alors oui
effectivement j'ai encore plus chaude
am3 cavani ouais c'est le coup qu'on
attendait quand même s'il faut récupérer
la pièce a priori on va montrer ce coup
le coup qu'on attendait de la part de
shirov c'était celui de leur logique
oui tout à fait je prends la marée noire
répondent par d'un os 7 ben oui me faire
semblant d'âme cette salaires d'être
plus ou moins le seul si ce n'était pas
assez agressif pour cheyrou est là qu
est ce qu on passe sur son annonce m bah
je ne sais pas moi je pense que cette
annonce est le coup sûr des cats sur des
quatre les kabyles c6 tout simplement on
conserve nos pièces mais en perdant une
pièce je ne crois pas non plus pas de
piano sont inquiets c'est donc alors on
va montrer la voie renens très rares des
4 as a fait une fourchette fourchette
mais dans ce cas là il mort pour jouer
cavalier on sait cialis et six
attaquants la dame blanche voilà contre
attaque sur la dame le foot attaquer
mais si les blancs prennent rarement
reprendre du fou pour le rideau du grand
four en voilà ella a priori il n'y a
plus trop de problème puisque la
position est symétrique au niveau des
pions et comme des plus il ya plus de
chance attaque donc pas de problème pour
les noirs shirov dans cette position ne
joue pas d'un pont cavaliers évidemment
ouais ils jouent plus dynamique il faut
jouer dynamique d 4d kaboom
j'ai toujours un toujours un coup d'état
qui l'a toujours en province mais donc
il est sûr qu'il va récupérer une des
pièces toutes les personnes
il ya trois façons crise l'art et 3.3
viennent donc il peut récupérer une
voire même une seconde si les noirs face
font une erreur c'est non mais par
exemple voire même prendre les trois
voire même pas de nom mais l'a par
exemple une erreur pour les noirs se
serait de prendre en d4 puisque l'on
permet une pièce probablement je crois
vous laisse hélas ses larmes au
programme comprend des quatre fautes pas
sûr parce qu'il n'a pas été jouée en
cavalier attaque le fond de cale l'uqam
adeese salaire très décente et en été
c'est sur sa paire progrès du matériel
de façon assez lourde ces cinq sets 3 c5
c3 et le fouet prix les fouilles perdu
tout simplement oui une fois plus de
cases il suffit de sortir la dame
donc c'est une ouverture assez piège
dans cette position faire attention gris
tchouk préfère je vais fawcett bon voilà
il faut rendre la pièce est pas paniquer
donc là on note que bon des points 5 est
possible de prendre cinq faux il faut
prendre une des deux pièces comme il
faut pas non plus en faire trop
des promotions que c'était possible mais
ça avait l'inconvénient de fermer la
colonne peu les voies seulement je
voulais jouer avec il a donc le dame
prend le 4 un agriculteur ça bien c'est
à lui maintenant les noirs sauf le ghana
puis à saint jouan carige ici c'est
tranquille
oui et c'est le début terminée et shirov
a mis ses pieds son centre je suis remis
ses pièces au centre à noter que la
position a l'air plus ou moins
équilibrés quand même ses fans puisqu'il
ya ces 6 suivi de dessins qui arrive
ouais mais noir vont donc égalisé la
situation et centre vous récupérez des
temps sur le fouet et développer leur
offre et sur la dame et surtout la dame
c'est à dire que là quand on sera là on
attaquera le fou quand on sera là on
attaquera la dame donc les pièces de
chercheurs vont devoir bouger a priori a
pas de point pour les noirs cependant
ici sa demande donc un jeu très très
active de la part de shirov puisque s'y
lient à ces six des 500 rien c'est égal
moins chiante joue le coup bien vu f4 et
commence à jouer contre le canadien où
j'étais moi là c'est ce qu'a indiqué mal
placé une menace
f5 et ce calibre encore plus mal placé
donc c'est toujours un coup d'état est
toujours un coût de ces six donc la
logique
en attaque le fou alors l'erreur
évidemment ce serait tout le fossé 4
puisqu'il y aurait des 5 avec nous tout
est fait avec une fourchette
je me fourchette une partie thématique
fourchette de bonheur je vais te voilà
le bon sens toujours montré ses séides
et parce que dans le début de l'e3 voilà
faute étrange vous met le feu quelque
part des cinq attaques la dame lath à
kadam faire date à se dérober deux mois
est normal et maintenant et bien c'est
aux joueurs de jouer et il ya les
mélanges de jours chaque yaris est une
menace parce que ce pion serait très
bien placé pour démolir le roi que tôt
ou tard et surtout le cavaliere pas de
case à sa disposition et alors il ya
plusieurs images aux marquis mais j'aime
le petit cavalier on sait pas où il ira
deuxième remarque une fois que pure et
9,5 qui contrôle la case aussi ce donc
les noirs ne peuvent plus tenir la
colonne eu en jouant fois au 6 mai
imaginant petit rock tout simplement
imaginer au petit rock qu'on peut mais
tout ça je me saper une pièce j'aime
pression puisque la youri f5 f5
quelle est la suite mais là il faudrait
jouer car il ya chez lui puisque sinon
sont 15 h katia g3 oui il a hini
lecavalier balle assez mal placé et
nommé deux le gros inconvénient de cette
pression stéphane c'est que le phocéen
va sortir peut-être sur les cases f4
enfin il a un très beau champ d'action
sont toutes les cases point on peut plus
bouché la colonne eux c'est un problème
le fou s'est vite on sait pas trop
comment le sortir et puis de leca liège
suite n'en parlons plus ouais il est
horriblement mal placé bref ce pion f5
donne des très belles chances
d'atteindre ce qui explique qu'il faut
pas tous les rêves 5 et d'où le coup de
grisou nous le coudray tchouk voilà est
rien qui lui-même
il n'empêche qu'ils bloquent le pian
voilà tranquille c'est pas mal le
problème c'est que le fou ces huit
maintenant est bloqué par ses propres
pions alors remarque stéphane c1 c'est
pareil pour les blancs c'est pareil pour
les blancs effectivement et oui tu as
des symétries donc la différence c'est
simplement qu'à régis 6 alors qu'il peu
moins bien placé peut-être que le
cavalier blanc qui va arriver à se
positionner plus vite vers le centre ou
alors on s'approche on s'approche de la
vérité
le truc c'est que simplement donc le
cavalier blanc et sur un bon parcours
pour accéder à la casse aux 5
oui alors que le cavalier noir qui lui
avait placé plus près de las cases au
caté en fait plus longue ni revenu plus
loin parce qu'il est alors que celui là
est à trois temps un 2 2 et 3 et 3 par
ces cases là est en vie or la lui il y a
quatre temps à lomié à être concernés
comme ça on ne sait même pas par où il
va passer oui il va être obligé de
passer par la suite oui je suis la tête
ces 6es au cateau allons donc
autre remarque les noirs n'ont pas
encore ok donc les bleus on entend
davantage de temps et vont être les
premiers à envahir la case super
contrôle et on voit que c'est un duo de
quasi essais les blancs qui arrive en
premier dessus d'ailleurs ils vont tout
de suite des deux petit rocks des
logiques cavaliers f3 est le souffre et
aaron ou cool avec l'étouffer calcio
italien fit quand même c'est le plan
alors c'est un plan qui nous vient tout
droit de ninkovic info spitz il faut
montrer le parcours des cavaliers
pourquoi il est venu ici c'est pas c'est
pas pour se mettre à l'abri c'est pour
venir en aide 7 puis en d6 et enfin sur
la case de quatre fortes
c
or courant quasiment obligatoire non
mais c'est le parcours atyrau déploie sa
pièce qui est très mal placé angers 6
donc s'il le faut c'est éviter tant il
est en passe perspective la seule pièce
mal placé c'est le cavalier justice donc
il faut le il faut le replacer tout
simple si tu voyages suite les blancs
c'est dire la force des grands joueurs
marquez et les conjoints ont toujours
des pièces du passé fou des deux fous
des deux index ou fou il est quand même
plus actif que l'on poussé lui parce que
il peut aller à gauche quand même ici
une petite visite sur la gauche alors
que les blancs n'ont pas joué ces trois
là n'ont pas joué ces trois exemples en
bouche et leur fou donc le fou peut
sortir par là alors que les deux sont
opposées ces moments là qu'il peut pas
le fou s'est vite lui est bien enfermé
et la gretsch jouer un coup un peu
surprenant il faut bien le reconnaître
il s'agit du coup à cinq mais il veut
limiter l'action de ce fou limiter
l'action de ce fou c'est vrai mais est
ce qu'on peut se permettre de perdre un
temps dans ce genre de position
honnêtement je n'en suis pas sûr
peut-être il aurait dû simplement vous
centrez les hisse en quarts et oui alors
vraisemblablement il est probable que
dans cette position il avait peur de
l'avancée du pion b
peut-être en bep cap puis en bessin qu
il faut faire une attaque contre la
chaîne de pion à terre voilà je ne sais
pas exactement de quoi il peut regretter
choc mais en tout cas il a joué à cinq
perdre du temps mais il fait il est
peut-être éviter l' attaque de minorités
est ce qu on appelle ce que tu venais de
dire beckett dessin alors la taille des
minorités une petite précision ces
contenants minorité de pions oui il ya
quatre contre quatre coins c'est pas du
tout c'est un genre de sous varié en
voilà une
notre hacker minorités sans minorité au
prix fort effectivement ça pose d'autres
problèmes alors qu'avant mais alors
remarque ici après à 5
on ne voit pas comment les blancs
peuvent améliorer leur jeu ouais c'est
pas facile c'est le problème puisque m
le cavaliere au sein et en espace vous
permet de centraliser une tour par
exemple tout à main
oui tout un foin attaque le fouet cette
c'est vrai bon on peut faire ça bon il y
aura foule 6-1 voie semble dégagée et
ensuite sait pas trop comment on va
améliorer la jlrv trouve évidemment il
faut ouvrir les lignes quand on est
mieux développer principe pour tous les
internautes qui regardent
quant à la mère développement ouvrir les
lignes maximum voilà c4 alors sens quand
on n'a pas la paire de fou ça se discute
ça se discute d'ailleurs dans le début
et si on regarde on peut appliquer cette
règle sillage il a ouvert parce qu'ils
étaient mieux développer l' effet le
petit rock enfin tu mentionnes donc sa
taille et donc c4 c4 alors à priori
menace rien une chose est sûre c'est
qu'il faut a priori pas prononcé quatre
parce que les pièces blanches vont
devenir beaucoup trop forte
si on imagine normalement on dit si on
prend ces quatre créatures isolé ça la
vraie la presse français 4 ça va être
avec quelqu'un pour ces cas d'échec et
pièces mais on va pas aller en gros
c'est gratuit qui va être suivi après
son bref on ne peut absolument pas
prononcé quatre cas de choc fait qu'il y
ait cette c'est normal il revient sur la
caisse de 4.25 logique ouvrir ouverture
des lions prendre et tenir cet ancien il
profite de son avance de développement
pour développer sa tour à noter que le
coût à 5 degrés toute la maintenance à
verre
ennuyeux peut-être maintenant ennuyeux
pour qui pour john a
pourquoi je suis passé puis on leur plus
faible à gauche du cou alors qu'il
n'avait pas joué à cinq
c'est peut-être moins fort cette
continuation pour les blancs c'est
probable c'est probable puisque le tuera
s'inquiète-t-on prises dans certains -
il est en tout cas taclé par le fou qui
moyen d'à côté c'est difficile parce
qu'ils craignent faiblesse mais limitent
l'expansion aussi des blancs donc le jeu
d'échecs tout est question de choix mais
bien tout faire c'est votre choix
ces peintres fauves 61.6 pas mal puisque
ce fou en tête étaient pas très très
actif ici au moins une tape sur le plan
des quatre voiliers et en plus beaux et
les plus repris dans vos sets il ya plus
de tours est un gagnant ton âme en
beauce est maintenant bref le [ __ ] ou
une belle claque un coup développement
comme fou 17 et être plus prudents parce
que là le coup suivant justement de
shirov le coup suivante shirov fait mal
fait mal fait mal et très mal alors
qu'elle est l'idée alors une fois de
plus c'est un grand principe aux échecs
vous regardez cette position et vous
vous dites qu'elle est ma pièce qui ne
joue pas alors on réfléchit bien on voit
que le foot est roi
il ya eu pas mal il a cependant viré 5
le cavalier le 3d super ils menacent
d'envahir lakatos un bon la tour en f1
on peut effectivement la mettrons un oui
ça c'est un coup donc on aurait pu jouer
la tour st est parfaite mais le fou des
deux on ne sait pas ce qu'on va en faire
longtemps il a un petit oeil sur le pur
et simple mais ce puis 1,5 et bien
défendu alors oui bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est très bizarre et donc on va
enlever ses flèches
ouais voilà et on va montrer ce qu'on
aurait pu faire le fou des deux dans
cette position qu'en aurait-il pu faire
normalement on se dit le fou d2 on le
passe par là ah oui on essaie de
l'avenir h4rem et on peut pas et on ne
peut pas parce qu'elles font office qui
parlent fort et le duo fois six dames
débute donc ça ne sert à rien donc ici
shirov a trouvé un très beau très beau
geste technique il joue b2b cas qu'ils
font fi du pur 1,5 avancée profite du
plus récent qui avance et surtout il
veut
il faut mettre son fou sur cette case
b4y la dégage d'abord alors b4
maintenance de solutions pour les noirs
soit ils prennent c'est possible de
gagner pousse
ouais ouais si on prend il faut parce
que sinon sinon les blancs menace de
prendre nommément à 5
c'est probablement et puis le coup b6 on
n'a pas spécialement envie de jouer ça
ouvrirait trop de lignes salaires
d'affaiblir les cases des cases blanches
donc les tubes décide de fermer le jeu
il joue à 4 à 4 et à chéraute faut
maintenant que les 5 voilà on est à
venir le fou l'avenir sur l'a4 et promet
une belle 15 % foot ou simplement très
belle qui crée une case control ont été
écrites c'est important ça a pas l'air
comme ça mais c'est très important
alors est-ce que non quand même pas pu
prendre b4 parce que la torah 8 comme ça
on est petit au moins un petit oeil sur
le pion à 2 alors c'est perdez du temps
quand même de krems a perdu 4 way
comparé à l'autre variante non puisque
la faune cran le la tour peut venir en
huit attaquants adams et c'est tout à
fait fort c'est ça leur logique on met
deux cavaliers sur les casots 5 voilà
est maintenant à toi jouer n'est
peut-être pas de coups simples mais pas
tout simplement cette pression est
extrêmement délicate et extrêmement
difficile mais c'est vrai que les blancs
contrôle bien tout quoi un pièce au
centre le fougueux v4 est superbe et
puis la torah 8 finalement même si le
contrôle le pion à 2 ans voit pas trop
comment tu peux augmenter ce fief au
bessat qui est menacée
oui effectivement il faut b5 ça c'était
c'est assez important c'est à dire que
dans la vie on touche à occuper tout cas
je me dis un turbulent des cinq donc ya
pas de foot et 5 c'est un peu différent
la tournée donc finalement mais regarde
bitumeux calme pas voilà joue à 4 et 5
des cinq libérant une casse pour son fou
en fait très chaud qu ils essayent de
fermer tandis que je suis refait c'est
d'ouvrir c'est pour ça qu'il ne prend
pas en bekale tours 8
donc apte à claude à servir de 5,5
logique pour pas perdre de temps et
install de carrier au centre qu'à
valider fils logique aussi on veut venir
sur la case de 4 et rituels m'en fous
mais 4 et là problème pour greg shaw qui
n'a pas spécialement envie de venir au 4
mai tout simplement dans cette position
il n'a plus de coups mais n'a pas le
choix parce que les normes les blancs
hamas menace peut être eux mêmes de
prendre le cavalier non puisque là ils
se retrouveraient oui si on prend le
cavalier il ya dame prend en fou et
damages cynique et d'un match moyen
intéressant je ne crois pas non
honnêtement je pense que les normes non
simplement peut-être pas de coups dans
cette position tout simplement pas de
comptes peut-être que la menace il faut
prendre les six justement peut-être
ouais ouais ouais c'est non mais j'ai
pas on avoue réfléchir à cette question
qu'est ce que peuvent jouer les noirs et
bien je ne sais pas donc riccio qui a
joué cavalier ou quatre ans quand on a
quand même envie de jouer wick a l'air
bien vous une cavaliers bien placé mais
la met juste qu'il ya un problème
l'aïe un seul ça va ouvrir la ligne ça
va ouvrir les livres exactement cherokee
est toujours mieux développer on peut le
voir ici légèrement mieux il joue fou
prend cavaliers aux 4 quand même je
reçois des mines savoir s'il est pris à
tempo justement losc comme il a maigri
je veux faire mais lui veut ouvrir ou
pas mais bon sang ne sais pas je connais
pas le temps de réflexion et
malheureusement pour ces partis alors
allez on peut prendre une cuve
alors que nous avons il ya une légère
cagade vidéo mais elle a été réparée
voilà est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut prendre avec du pian f
alors là parce qu'on peut prendre les
deux des pions f qui ont dit oui alors
c'est la grande question effectivement
stéphane que se serait-il passé c'est
que tout quelques options oui voilà ce
qu'il est pris avec l'option d'aliments
la halle en voyant les internautes sont
posée puisque oui alors là on dort là
josé je crois donc comme tu as suisse
est partie en direct tu as tu sais
exactement aux comptes qui se passe dans
cette position là
les lignes sont ouvertes donc les blancs
attaque damage 5 d'un machin qui
démarchent 5
oui 5 c'est bien vu la menace titille
les noirs est ce qu est une menace déjà
est ce que peut-être d'un fcf saleh
d'être peut-être tour c'est cet os 6 ans
et 16,7 ça a commencé après ça va dit
donc c'est 3g pour ces trois courses et
trois en fait damev 7,3 pour venir en
géant j'ai trois ou venir en 6 7 et
continué d'attaquer le roi 2007 pour ses
7,7 à mettre ses potes c'est pas mal
bref beaucoup de perspectives donc dans
cette position les noirs a priori un
coup logique
il s'agit de développer ces pièces dont
elle a développé ses pièces pour une
fête ou faut aussi ce faux si c'est josé
qui connaît là qui connaît bien la
variante faut aussi c'est logique est
donc maintenant avec shirov il attaque
toujours pas ce qu'il fait toujours les
troubles attaque ouais moi qui leur ai
joué cinq lots a joué c'est une simple
question attaquant mais ils attaquent
tout le temps donc un tout à fait
l'attaquant le fou c'est une simulation
qui tient compte des styles respectifs
des joueurs
la food et c'est totalement fou 17 et
pour cela on n'en ayant pas non
maintenant il y avait trop de reprendre
et de prendre l'a5 où il doit éliminer
ce cavalier
voilà mais plus on prend 1,5 ou encore
des lignes tout à fait là on voit que
les deux pions blancs sont passés
l'instant ils sont passés derrière les
pions noirs
oui ils sont le même passé derrière les
pions de la famille cet attaquant la
dame
oui hélas donc dame g4 d'objecteurs
menace de l'association anticor 6e s'il
faut prendre une sacrée longueur
on vous la montre juste juste pour voir
maintenant le coût du professionnels
locaux le coup au coup d'état quand
corps d'objets trois dames neutre en
attaque encore les s'aperçoit que la
tour d énormes difficultés
1 alors pourquoi donc moi je suis simple
ces tours 8e tour au vide qui brille de
suite
m6 est toujours là coude attaque we have
seen as dame proche des 7 matches oui il
faut faut juste seulement jouer g6 voilà
fouet ou foule ici sont fous j'ai 6 mai
geste vis maintenant damev 4 oui
toujours menace menace un oui madame à
venir avec le baas et mat 1 et non j'ai
fait et ici ça devient extrêmement dur
extrêmement dur après tour 6-7 qui gagne
donc variante assez longue mais il y
avait de la fac en fait on va remontrer
le début de la vente stéphane parce que
ça devant de feydit coup ouais on va
parler vraiment accessible si c'est
facile et c'est pas facile après fou
points 4 donc ça c'était la pression des
parents et surtout on prend sur tu me
prends sur le sur l'ocré tuant croquer
l'on prend on
damages 5 on commence à menacer
d'envahir sur toutes les cases et il ya
une vente forcée qui fait que avec
l'avancée du pion au f5 et bien les
blancs obtiennent un jeu extrêmement
fort contre le roi noir ses soutiens f5
qui du coup on fait les blancs en trois
pions contre 2 contre le roi oui et
c'est un facteur décisif d'ailleurs je
te précise juste un truc c'est que le
couple dame cavalier est beaucoup plus
fort que le couple d'un fou pour
attaquer pour internet et c'est vrai que
là on voit que le fouet f6 et la dame
des 8
vont défendre contre damage 5 et cabrio
5 d'avancé c'est pas si c'est un fake en
tout cas ça donne des idées lorsqu'il
entre suspense autre remarque également
qu'on a déjà fait dans toutes les
éditions précédentes de diagonale quand
le cavaly il ya plus de cavaliers
abscisse pour défendre le roi est bien
un diable attaque
ouais donc ils sont ainsi pas un
cavalier c'est un fou donc il ya du
jeudi les chances d'attac great choc
après fou prend 4 a repris du plomb des
pour ne pas laisser justement soit les
jours est agressée et puis c'est que
jérôme fait très fort en attaque aux
ménages si on veut avoir la tête quand
même oui il voulait pas affaiblir en
fait ça en droit gratuitement
voilà pour la rive voilà c'est dit au
moins je vais je vais serrer un peu ont
néanmoins il au moins une jambe cassée
ou quatre oui tous rêvent d un
je veux que ça soit moi ça ne passe que
là ils prouvent immobile quasiment
obligé d'ailleurs puisque yves et noir
menacé de prendre le pion des quatre oui
vos choix des cinq mois je veux des cinq
des six décennies ça c'est bon le chien
qui a dit ça dans les positions de
millau de jeu quand vous avez le temps
passe et il faut l'avancé ouais donc là
pas de problème pour shirov qui vit 90
pas mieux que d'avancer le coup d'état
qui l'a tempo pour le ciss faut aussi ce
qu'ils peuvent pour bloquer la casse des
5 pourrait tout à fait dit des joueuses
étaient fans le coude à taxer et la
proposition coups d'attaqué évidemment
c'est quand même de jouer décibels voilà
c est fait chez roth
c'est quand même gênant mais ça y va
quand même oui quand même toujours donné
des en fait chiron 6 ainsi que si on
peut donner un pion une pièce ont fait
voilà exactement mais il faut il faut
que ça y est une justification
positionnable oui oui c'est ça méar
tactique pas tactique positionnelle pose
d'une attaque un pion un sacrifice
d'options de pièces qui attaque d'abord
chez rough le fait schifflange
alors question stéphanois une question
qui me qui m'interpelle qui m'attirait
faucons des cinq cures en reste il n'a
pas l'air bon salaire d'avant
effectivement ce que là il ya la rioja
tour c5 et ouais effectivement tour ses
5 pourquoi
eh bien on attaque le fou des cinq une
fois de plus un avec la tour elf ou et
se fout des 5es cloud et saas et la dame
derrière voilà ce qui bouge boum c'est
la dame qui en prend pour son grade
voilà qui en prend pour son grade tout à
fait
et fait artificiellement final c'est un
final de la dame qui reprochait on ne
peut pas prendre le pion en d5
il sait que l'ariège à cause des
enfilades exactement fou 17 dollar
dallas donc il faut 17 c'est un mauvais
coup en revanche cédé 7 c'est un mauvais
coup alors josé conques aurait-il fallu
faire ben a toujours développé ses
pièces
c'est toujours les principaux jeux
qu'est la pièce qui n'a pas encore été
développés à la source est vite et bien
tout ça c'était le bon coup stéphane et
wiltord ses élites ce qu'il aurait pu
faire ça puisque là si on prend le pion
alors attendre si on prend le
questionnement nous manquait ce qui se
passait dans sap alarmant oui c'est pas
juste mais c'est bon on fait vraiment
pas l'air bon qu'est ce qui se passe sur
ce but on a laissé le fou emprise ouais
alors que cela se passe attention les
noirs font une audace il menace tout le
tour que l'on tourne et tourne le pion
des cinq blessures voilà donc a priori
on envisage de prendre le foot
ouais et là il y aurait deux tours caen
tours pour prendre pour alors on cloue
la tour d un donc pourtant dame est
impossible voilà donc il faut reprendre
l'info reprendre la tour avec une pièce
de plus et maintenant il apparaît tout
de suite la dérive des glaces achat qu
un léger courant et le fourbe et 4 qui
en prend pour son grade depuis six mois
là tout à fait par la donne maintenant
est-ce que c'est grave au broc h1h1 d'un
premier 4 à noter que la tour peut pas
venu faire un coup comme tour c'est
cette puisqu'il y aura un mode du
couloir
oui tout à fait en fait c'est plus actif
que ce qu'il a joués en gros il a plus
de chances sont maigres et le pion aux 6
et peut-être les blancs en vue jouer
autre chose jouer des six peut-être non
oui oui c'est ça le fait alors
recommandé d'ailleurs le regarder voilà
parce que la pression les bleus ne sont
pas obligés de prendre puisque ça a pas
l'air bon c'est cette posture l'après
tour s'est vite il aurait pu jouer des
six peut-être menaçant le 17
voilà je crois que c'est je suis pas sûr
que ce soit le coût
je sais tout repenser vitoux avancer
vite des six tours prend c'est lui qui
prend d'abord sévi il faut laisser la
tour derrière l'option d'un pont phu
comprends vous prend maintenant le foot
attaquer maintenant les matons dessine
c'est bien dit menace d arrêter cette là
et là c'est moi ils ont moins clair que
ce qui serait parti d'une belle position
d'attaqué et noir ont réussi à alléger
un peu la tension en échangeant une
paire de tours et puis le karyu 5 est
maintenant était vraiment prise in plus
aussi solide qu'avant lui n'a plus son
soutien
donc après dessins qu'il fallait jouer
pour ces 8 pourront échanger des pièces
principalement est allégé d'attention et
changer les pièces donc la n va tout
jouer ou moins fois en fout des sept
fous 17
alors là c'est en fait c'est cuit
puisque shirov à trouver un plan il va
sacrifier une pièce c'est le pleurer ça
écrit quelque chose c'est le plan de
cherokee joue donc cavalli en fait il
rappelé et il faut qu'il trouve toujours
un moyen de sacrifier une pièce
documents soient toujours un coup d'état
qu'en fait tu es le seul coup la taxe et
d'opposition sega va nécessiter ouais
donc ça ce qui est impressionnant
alors première remarque le cavaly étant
prises le cas mais par le pion par
l'option alors nous mêmes notre première
remarque le cavalier attaque
oui on respecte la règle numéro un du
coude attaque
ouais ouais c'est après celle qu'avait
dit emprise respecte la règle numéro 2
de chez rough ces sacrifices
à noter a aussi pu influencer les astres
cndd et zaoui alors effectivement
puisqu'ils auraient pu monde et prendre
les c6 et le fou 17 et récupérer avec
des pions pincer pour les blancs de
récupérer parce qu'il est cloué on peut
se dire je fais d'un v6 et chaque
intermédiaire même salle une fois que
c'est parti je bouge le fou mais la
liasse ou c5 et c5 protégé par la tour
attaque la dame et après en récupère le
fou et c'est tout simplement gagnant
très facilement pour les blancs les
noirs en reparle plus joué le coup
voyons dans cette position oui non juste
avant pas pas de s'envoyer d'un échec
doit par exemple tour à 7 septembre
c'est pas mal ça a pas l'air bon c'est
pas mal un fossé 5-5 et vidéo il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de jeu il a poussé
scène qui attaquent la tour abc c'est le
propre de la science mais s'il se passe
ici c'est bien je crois que c'est ça qui
est plus fort mais
moi tout est faux dans cette position
tout est fait pour quoi et bien
simplement parce que les noirs n'ont pas
de menaces ils ont toujours leurs fous
emprisonné puis les lens en tant que
j'ai de prendre tout de suite on voit
quand même un beau duo tour aux petits
oignons
c'est durant ces durant laquelle les c6
fait très mal d'autant plus que le
cavalier qui semble emprise ne l'est pas
que ça c'est délicat voire peut-être
prendre du puy du fou alors prendre du
fouet c'était possible alors qu'est ce
qui se passe si on prend du fou
n'entreprendrait des pions qui ont dit
oui c'est moins grave ça leur moins
graves
c'est très grave quand même stephen
améliorer dame
d'annoncer cette par exemple alors dame
ses citoyens ou toute façon il est plus
vraiment de coup dans cette position si
elle c'est cette traversée des 107 117
sur les essais de temps 17 3 les sets
tout à l'air extrêmement fort soit tour
17 sa soif ou des 6 ou alors on va pas
s'arrêter sur des coups comme ça oui
simplement on va dire dans cette
position que l'option c6 est extrêmement
fort qu'il est soutenu par deux tours
n'est que les deux options qui se
conçoit bien trempé 7 soit ces sept
c'est en attaque la dame on voit ce qu
elle fait ensuite on a tous accès aux
ulis trop les pièces - voilà exactement
donc dans cette position c'est vraiment
désespéré dont les noirs simplement là
après qu'un essai 6 gré chucky de la
très très chaud il à chaud et tout homme
ses huit pairs la dame par l'adam
et oui parce que la chine va sauter sur
l'occasion oui alors d'ailleurs
effectivement pour une fois il a
l'occasion de mettre une pièce emprise
de faire un échec et beignets la dame et
un coup d'état qu'il est très content et
le coût attractif
la double attaque il est alors il joue
de son père qu'elle armanios est alors
ça c'est un coup qu'il faut étudier donc
c'est une découverte c'est une
découverte puisque le cavalier est sorti
faisant échec à adam et latour attaque
la dame donc en fait le cavalier peut
être en prise dit froid quand lass a
aucune importance
faut pas qu'ils sont prises par la dame
il faut pas qu'il sent prise par la main
de la dame vient de répondre entre plans
et lorsqu'à fourchette de cavaliers le
sur la dame
le cavalier déjà mis aux prises par des
âmes non c'est vrai ce qui compte c'est
surtout la découverte va se retrouver à
découvert de la toile faut prendre cette
en garang alain cavalier bon rythme et
mémé tout reprend sa vie au grand dam
voit la super bien très jolie tourcoing
alors là on se dit c'est gagnant
facilement message ou messages ou faut
prendre cette pour concept walhalla on
reprend notre souffle six références son
pion encore d'une 15 mai 6 et 6 alors
gratecos dame vaut à peu près de tours
fin de tour sont un peu plus fort qu'une
dame oui mais y'a tout contrefout plus
un pion des six très avancé ça fait
beaucoup d'atouts pour les blancs alors
la question stéphane qu'est ce que les
blancs vont attaquer à partir de
maintenant
et oui c'est pas facile à rien si ce
n'est pas parce que je suis refaite avec
toujours mais il faut peut-être
consolidé d'abord le pion le pion b5
puisque la dame pour l'instant deux
doigts brenta j'ai le pion oui c'est
bien attaqué par le fou donc il faut
peut-être essayer de consolider ce pion
et ensuite peut-être attaqué le pion à
4000 sable pour l'instant c'est le seul
objectif
des blancs le seul point faible des noix
on va dire c'est ce qu on a quatre donc
shirov très logiquement autour des 5
bien vu stéphane il défend donc la barre
des 5 même moi j'ai vu appartient ans
alors n'attendez 5dans tour des cinq ça
protège le pian bessengue la tour est
bien placé la petite taille aussi sur le
plan et 5 je suis pas sûr que jouer le
monial venir sur les 15,5 aussi peut
venir éventuellement sur le 4 e 5 on
peut passer comme ça voilà pour essayer
de me serrer des menaces en est la
critique joue bien il active c'est au
tour c'est un échec
oui roef de un taux à 9,8
on voit que la tour on veut passer eh
oui ici parce que la boum ça gagne la
dame presque n'ont pas tout à fait mais
là shearer maintenant a tout calculé
il calcule tous cherchent en même temps
c'est un euro 5
une superbe transformation qui va
arriver le 5 juin il veut en fait ils
arrivent à débloquer ce fou 17
évidemment shirov peut voir pousser des
6-17 et créent des menaces très forte
avait 100 kg ont effectivement tour
s'est vite menace menace tour s'est vite
on ces deux gagnants la dame ou tour six
séances ccq père à la dame pour une vie
tourne au drame puisque l'année sera
pour y mettre tout à fait donc c'est
très fort enrichissante s'en fout
girondins a cure n'en a cure n'en a cure
qui veut donc dire qu'ils s'en fout
ouais pas encore tout à fait donc autant
le dire avec des mots simples tours 7
pour cela il va pas comme de foot en
fait il va il va récupérer enfin hyper
adam mais récupère le fou ce qui fait
qu'ils échangent saddam contre tours est
fou oui ce qui fait un échange qui est
pas tout la mauve et d'autre et surtout
la mesure des six très avancé de toute
façon oui ici il n'y a pas le choix on
peut pas jouer
n'importe quoi que tout peut pas jouer
il faut vite puisqu'ils auraient 17
il y aura des salésiens tout de suite
donc les objets jouets tour 1 c2 gagne
la dame tout reprend 17 pour prendre
deux rois promeut deux et on arrive dans
une finale deux tours avec égalité
matérielle donc là évidemment on est
obligé de se dire shirov a déconné tout
simplement nommé puisque là il ya les
finales au tour sont toutes nul et
aucune chance donnée en finale auto en
fait tous les petits nyalas tout de
suite tout prend qu on bessette avec 2
kg ont passé très fort wailly menace ton
confiant mais c'est très tranquille
bessette donc là délicat quand même la
salle des fêtes les pions en finale deux
tours le plus important c'est les pions
centraux et celui de shirov est un petit
peu plus avancé donc c'est très
important
oui et il a trouvé beaucoup plus active
et le roi de shiro fait mieux aussi
parce que la tour noire peut aussi
s'activer finalement pareil au fait quoi
de même sur la surface - mais peut-être
le roi noir est moins actif que le roi
blanc parce que le roi blanc quand même
bien centraliser la tour blanche aussi
tout de suite active alors que les noirs
un principe important en finale deux
tours on ne peut gagner que si le roi
est actif et la tour et active les
foulées 2009 50 ans est là qu est ce qu
on voit le roi blanc tout simplement il
a un chemin tout tracé il va aller vers
le toit des 15 k o 56 alors à noter que
en faisant ça il va laisser le pion noir
aléas d'un bon signe il va laisser
purement aller à dame ouais
effectivement mais c'est la partie c'est
très joli
b 6 donc il y avait cette voie là on va
on gagne option b 6
voilà une force et non en faire quelque
chose puisque la ici prend le plan b si
c'est fini oui oui donc la gretsch
hawkes eddie je vais mettre ma tour sur
la case d3 ça a l'air pas mal fait tour
ces deux échecs mais le 3 le roi sait
que c'était pas possible puisqu'il ya
encore échec
ouais on revient en d4 ça ça s'avère
risqué donc tout avant roi et tour pour
gagner le tour c'est obligatoire tour
des trois échecs et là ça devient super
chaud oui bah oui rouault cinquième a
commencé y ait cinq curveiller shirov il
s'est trompé en 5 curieux puisque là les
noirs maintenant il joue au 3e 3 hélas
le pion bal adam voilà et on voit pas
comment les blancs peuvent l'arrêter a
effectivement donc c'est le sait on sait
la langue se dit abbas à déchirer ofida
c'est super chaud il s'est planté il
faut pas qu'ils aient ce problème
exemple 17
ouais bon c'est une possibilité et bien
simplement e 2 e 2 et voilà et là c'est
fini
oui parce que je suis puisqu'au coup
d'après on joue pour corruption et dames
ouais ou dame diop tout de suite avec
échec moi c'est terminé
donc que trois on se dit c'est les noirs
qui sont en avance parce qu'ils ont une
tour derrière l'option blanc alors que
le tueur noir lui les freelances them is
here enfin le gros lot
c'est l'autoroute moi aussi alors voila
moi aussi ce menace matt menace mal et
ça c'est un jour un coup tous les coups
d'attaqué tout le collège en collège
vétérinaire de huit tombes et 8 échecs
et mat
jusque là le roi aussi ce contrôle à
cazères scène de fuite voilà un laurent
noir peut pas sortir important donc la
6e place de sortie voilà et puis la
salers toujours bon pour les noirs
puisqu elle obtient toujours la dame
c'est sûr il fait droit aux sept tours
et sète nous contrôler le pion aux trois
petites anecdotes sont seconds ans
raconte que lorsque shirov à jouer ce
coup là il s'est levé avec le sourire le
second shirov non
je se glorifie rohff s'est levé avec le
sourire et donc il a su que il était
très tendu il dit cherfaoui déconner
quand il a vu un millier de places il
était content de ça deux se combinent
salah il est bon c'est gagnant
facilement shirov s'élève à priori avec
le sourire oui on sait que fear of n'est
pas un joueur très près des monstres à
travailler très donc quand il se fait
avec le sourire c'est qu'il attend son
tour c'est donc là la menace et violence
de jouer drac 17 probablement de 7 août
et non je ne sais pas laisser aller le
17 et puis roi problème 5 au cas où où
est peut-être peut-être souvent et
surtout au fait nommer la raison précise
surtout roi 17,3 c8 et puis on avance
ses pions voilà et en contrôle et en
contrôle avec la tour st je sais pas ce
que tu as raison c'est comme ça aussi
peut-être possible
vous vous rendez vous est roi c'est
cette somme importe ici il ya une option
pour les noirs on voit que jouer eux
deux sa perte très vite se perd très
vite survenir seulement 17 3 17
et oui nombreuses dessertes en commander
7 à 3,17 latour attaque le kg alors des
clés noires joue autour des 2 d2 mais ça
c'est très passifs ils allaient les
noirs et les blancs leroy france et
cette menace entre 17 et sur échec
matinée noire
peut-être tout simplement reprend pions
non oui oui tout le tout sous terre je
laisse voir campion et vidéo en as
encore 17 c'est fini donc ici il peut
pas tolérer une position passive quelque
chose qui joue autour des 4 pas mal de
salaire bien ça a l'air bien puisqu'il
vous venir sur la classe e 4 effet
redonne et fair dames puisque paraît pas
protégés par le pian les blancs peuvent
plus ça y est ce qu'on va voir
oui on va voir ce qui se passe rodez est
voilà quand même quand même c'est ce qui
c'est curieux tours 4 oui hélas si tu
vas faire du oui alors est-ce que bond
puisque on regarde tout reprendre 4 pour
prendre chanteront et moi cet inédit
fait nos premiers et bien c'est les
noirs c'est les noirs qui font d'armand
1er juin
d un des huit d'un échec
roy bourget puis finale de dames avec
égalité matérielle donc a priori nul
qu'est-ce qui fait grise ou québec
retouches il abandonne
il avance que les suppléments alors
qu'il va faire dans mon premier c'est
quand même très très surprenant et c'est
très surprenant
qu'est ce qui se passe là on va voir et
dont on va voir great choc aurait pu
avancer
voilà notre offre avance aussi oui il
n'y a pas le choix la dame
voila voila choisi sernam les blancs
gratteux faire d'annoncé échec échec
important orage cette forme d ela est là
maintenant la petite joue le coup au top
ch le coup d'état qui me lie aux lois et
vii c'est superbe c'est bien vu pourquoi
la menace la menace dame j'ai vite j'ai
eu deux lattes maths et elle est
imparable
le seul coup qui par la menace de jouer
h5 ouais mais il ya d'alger vite échec
aux injustices les dames prendre j'ai
cette maladie ou d'un produit recettes
seimat
voilà tout simplement très très
technique alors c'est grave parce que
c'est le la dame noire en un ici peut
pas faire des chèques aux rats blancs il
y aurait fait s'il avait pu faire un
seul échec c'était sûrement à sauver on
se croirait dans une position de
la fin d'une étude oui les études c'est
des positions approximativement réels
qui ont été composés oui avec des
solutions très joli et là c'est le cas
puisque la dame papa c'est chacun qui
sont ruinés chiant quand celle qu'il
adore le beau jeu c'est un bon joueur
cette bourse est un bon joueur c'était
moi je super ce parti est très très
belle partie shirov a merveilleusement
bien joué donc alors il s'est un peu
voilent attaques y sommes pleins bachir
fabrice est parti puisque gris tchouk
arrive là d'un seconde partie shirov
gaffes et ghetto crampons remporté le
point égalisateur match on va voir la
gueule et on va voir la guerre va voir
les gars font rares et bien c'est donc
qu'on change de parti ou d'ailleurs
alors on va demander à gris chaud que
s'il avait gaffé auparavant il avait dit
oui mais finalement un projet du jeu et
puis il a continué à jouer et puis
finalement on se retrouve dans la
position finale ou ou là ces chiffres of
kings off c'est sûr of kings avant
vraiment voir ça comme ça c'est le
principe aux échecs
je suis qui gaffe le dernier mais perd
donc on va bien on va passer directement
à l'opposition
parce que on n'a pas trop le temps de
commenter en détail il faut voir la fin
on peut voilà justement tombe sur une
belle position
on peut commenter ici les blancs sont en
train d'attaquer sauvagement le roi noir
a pas encore ok
les blancs ont calmé le jeu il n'y a pas
trop d'attac ici on peut le roi blanc et
bien défendu bien florent noir mais la
chine offre combine comme toujours un
coup d'état quelle épreuve 3 quand même
me sacrifierai fait la tête la tour il
croit que ce sont donc là effectivement
on peut pas tolérer ça oui
rich iott front uni ça c'est la deuxième
partie du prêtre et jour en jour il est
rare qu est ce qu a laissé six 26 6
voilà c'est très curieux donc là une
pièce de moins mais la dame ces six
attaques lecavalier à 4 et ce qu'avait
dit la capte plus de cases mais pourquoi
il n'a pas fait avant alors ils
pouvaient pas le faire avant parce que
justement on va le
on va faire un coup intermédiaire aussi
bien français s'il ya d'hommes c6 v6
tout de suite et bien là ouais il y
avait quelque chose il y avait
simplement 4 des 6 je crois s'il ne fait
pas d'erreur
arica l'investissement est tout à fait
si si mais oui oui puisque le fou 3 et
la dame des deux protège la casse de
bessines cassayet cathy une erreur en
fait il a gaffé et il a gaffé est bon
mais il avait quand même du jeu c'est
qu'il ait dit oui donc sûr même si tout
de suite effectivement la dame est
encore en f2 donc on tient la classe b
si c'est possible d'aller dessus tout à
fait après cavaliers premiers froids
quand il prenait 3 donc on a une vie la
dame on vient de villadin et maintenant
dame c6 le carrelet populaire v 6
puisque c'est pas assez protégé tout à
fait donc il a joué cavalier ces cinq là
chez rough a tout de suite fait une
faute il a pris avec le cardiologue
prendre avec l'option fallait prendre
avec l'option pourquoi parce que ceux
qui avaient 17 pouvait venir sur la case
au 5 et ensuite nous tout cas trouvé du
contre jeu donc on vous passe les coudes
contre jeu on peut les on peut les
regarder rapidement
c'est sans les commenter cavell epr en
france ait bien joué
si on prend en main je vous rappelle que
pendant que l'on fait défiler les coûts
que les partis sont disponibles sur le
site officiel de la fédération
c'est waouh fi des points comme voilà et
pas uniquement d'ailleurs c'est aussi
disponible sur la tour infernale je
pense oui sur sur caution europe échec
sur on ne voit pas citer 16 cents à
l'heure mais si je n'étais pas dit non
mais si si pour les gens qui connaissent
pas tout à fait donc www.convatec.com
voilà www.katimavik.org également le
club de cassure qui est des partitions
sous ces quatre fawcett et il allait
bien il ya les liens ni les liens dames
2 comme ces six sages où il ya des
footballeurs opposé g5 tchouk attaque
d'ailleurs si rock celui qu'elle fait
que leur posent et doit attaquer doigté
qui lui est acquis lapointe a qu'avec
les pions l'idée est évidemment c'est
que le fou ces cas peuvent être très
fort on va jouer g6 et le match aussi
sera faible
voilà il n'ya pas bon on peut pas
reposer en fait à ce fou il n'y a pas
d'opposition à ce fou c'est pour ça
qu'il faut attaquer avec [ __ ] que leur
poser ça va être une attaque sur casse
blanche g6 voilà ça y est c'est l'heure
donc là tous reprendront bientôt pour
prendre en main
je reprends g6 champions fils est là il
fallait paraît-il prendre un g6 tout
simplement l'idée des blancs cette
soudaine g4 qui veut attaquer dur aussi
ce mot là il aurait fallu effectivement
prendre objectifs et sur dame g4 voilà
que je voulais que c'était le bon coup
touré fils sans doute d'ici au
terrorisme
toi aussi tu es là donc il ya d'options
plus pour les noirs mais il ya une
position extrêmement complexe saint cyr
scène qu'est ce qu'on voudra mais siii
c'est ça il faut 5 des 9 3 mais non je
ne sais pas d'ailleurs sur scène ce
qu'on fait tina maze trois mois
peut-être tour f 5 300 collégiens mais
dans cette position shirov il avait
prédit tour f 5 armand latour g5 ils ont
ils avaient ils étaient pas très bien
non comment il se fait attaquer ça
dépend dans son élément le couvre
chironex éléments qui ont du show qui
n'aime pas se faire attaquer gris chaud
qui disait aussi que bon il est donc il
avait gaffé d'april avait joué
tranquillement puis là où tu joues
contre jeu et il a envisagé la faute de
shirov en dix ans la réponse que
j'apporte à ça cette gaffe nepad est
difficile à voir pour un joueur humain
1 ah oui alors juste l'occurrence
surhumain je regarde donc pour un joueur
humain alors david essayer d'arracher
d'objets 4 mais bon c'est pas mal secoué
tour aux cartes c'est pas mal mais avec
leucate toujours un côté tactique ou
d'un malheureusement il ya dans ma
jeunesse beaucoup de contre attaque
coups de contre attaque attaque la tour
et menaces maths on menace match de
suite damas schmitt et il ya ya ya à
priori yann défense mais est ce que ça
marche pas cet ouvrage caf à la tourache
4 puisque ses protégés par le fou voilà
c'est pas mal ce couple que la tam est
attaqué par la tour et la tour protège
le pion à cette mêlée mais d'amd vite
d'amd 8 échec échec faut ensuite forcé
moyen par notre coup et maintenant tu
aurais fait tout simplement torresin on
voit que les pièces noires sont
complètement impuissante à défendre le
fouet alors c'est le seul coup ici ça
serait de jouer d'armes des six et là on
pourrait jouer foot ou reprend fou super
sur oasis mais il faudra aussi fait part
d'un profond obligés et là maintenant
fou prend ainsi ses chèques obligé de
jouer gros h 20 et d'en prendre
avec échec et mat c'est pas un baiser de
la mort on va dire ça c'est quoi c'est
un mode du coup je crois que améliorée
non c'est effectivement alors le baiser
de la mort on le rappelle c'est qu'on la
dame dit embarrassé droit sur la case à
côté de lui oui c'est pas pareil donc
damas juste un coup voilà je dirais que
j'ai vu cette position des choses qui
s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas comme je
suis en fait un jeu en attaque
peut-être qu'il va jouer tour fkt pas de
ça avec difficile à boire ça c'était la
surprise on va dire du deuxième tour si
on peut dire c'est la surprise des demi
finales ben c'est la surprise de en tout
cas la deuxième partie rich ou qui
égalise 1 partout
ça réduit la durée du match là deux
parties vigan cadrin par tous et encore
il n'y a plus que deux parties à venir
mais chez rough et devenus impitoyables
puis il a gagné la suivante effet nul
voila qu'est ce qu'il a fait dans la
partie des prêts et la viny il est en
forme il a encore attaqué encore
sacrifice d'ailleurs il ya comme un
effet pervers à ce championnat c'est que
les joueurs ont tendance à jouer très
solide et je suis rom
c'est le seul qui qui continue quand
même à sa grue et au final dit-il il
envoyait ses beaux ou moches mais c'est
au 10e bout ce match était beau parce
que comparativement aux autres matches
les gens essaient de faire mieux il est
pire pour jouer les départage un effet
pervers donc ouais c'est pas fermée
alors voyons on va on a encore une porte
une position en voix moment on apele
temps c'était fin n'a pas le temps on en
a vraiment pas le temps malheureusement
la pollution qu'on voulait nous montrer
c'est simplement une position la
particule adams a perdu mon impression
finale et bien tout simplement haussé
possibilité matérielle
we will égalité matérielle mais en fait
l'idée c'est qu'à ce propos plus bouger
peut plus bouger puis silva car tout
s'est fait par la cie bouge boom hyper
hype par quelque chose donc ça c'était
c'était affreux c'est à dire impression
mais là on n'a plus vraiment le temps
normal on va commenté stéphane la finale
à nantes contre chypre alors à noter
qu'après on est tous mais je me dis
qu'un un des favoris
vu ça sur tous les sites allemands près
alors il faut vous rappeler que shirov
avait perdu qu'en quart de finale
l'année dernière contre aunis six
pianistes une surprise oui un thème peu
dépité samedi cette année quand même
unis il n'arrivait plus affûtés oui
c'est une première chose est que si rose
n'a jamais perdu deux matches je force
n'a jamais perdu deux matches longs non
me compterons discipline où il avait
perdu c'était un match en deux sets en
deux parties on vient dans une partie
voilà wind on me l'avait perdue dans les
parties les biens des gens que ce
dernier se met rapidement les seniors à
ping donc pour l'instant chiron fait le
seul joueur sur terre
invaincu en match oui avant c'était
kasparov mais il a perdu contre kramnik
et schirrhoffen 28 rami comme killers
battu chronique donc shiren pour
l'instant a les nerfs extrêmement solide
non il faut bien le dire il avait braqué
contre les six pianos mais ça ça il n'a
pas peur de perdre non il n'a pas peur
de perdre alors justement les stats sont
là pour le prouver
puisque on regarde le parcours de
chiffres dans ce tournoi 22 parties eh
bien il ya une partie sur deux qui est
décisive il a fait onze bien enfin pas
lui et 20 pouces bien ouais on donc 11
15 et 20 défaites mais par contre
particularité tous les biens sont blancs
oui c'est à dire que alex est
chirurgienne beaucoup avec les dents on
espère beaucoup avec les neuf ans ouais
c'est ça voilà donc 11 gains il en a
gagné 8 il en a perdu 3 et il a joué
quatre matches de départage sur cinq est
donc plus suite moins de trois pour
l'instant pour scheer en vain ce
championnat voyez pour et pour un arbre
c'est pas mal aussi puisqu'il a gagné
toutes ses parties amélie blanche
oui alors annoncé impressionne aussi
alors justement le chiffre aurait fait
quatre matchs au départage alors que à
londres lui n'en a fait qu'un seul un
canton qualifiant autres car il fane
très gros match des parts de marché
commune plus
cinq victoires et 10 nuls dans ce
championnat pour attendre fascine 5 bien
évidemment il est fait par des 0 défaite
vous savez que si elle n'avait pas joué
au championnat kalichman aura encore
gagné ces qualifs l'année dernière parce
qu'elle n'a pas joué à l'année d'avant
il avait été éliminé par alejandro
annoncé lundi là c'est encore un autre a
éliminé rennes il a encore été champion
du monde j'ai vu autre chose comme ça
c'est que gulf on a toujours perdu
contre le champion du monde serre qu'ils
avaient été éliminés par anand en 98
ouais ils avaient été éliminés par
kalichman en 99
oui hélas il a été éliminé par shirov ah
ah oui ah ah ah ah non alors alors alors
alors alors alors oui allez le score
entre les deux joueuses score personnel
entre les deux joueurs
les parties donc il ya un total assez
conséquent de 28 et 15 parties ça fait
donc 43 parties jouées entre les deux
mois ce qui est pas mal en fait donc
partie longue longue et rapide d'un
tiers à 5 les deux résultats d'higuain
pour un monde cinq défaites pour un
nombre et 28 n'est donc plus 10 - 5 + 10
- saint-gobain davantage allant de
commandes à noter que quand on bat les
blancs il lui fait très mal puisqu'il a
si bien et de pertes
quand il avait neuf ans et équilibrée
trois gains pour shirov l'artiste c'est
un peu les boulons ça va être a priori
savait difficile pour shirov alors j'ai
lu
sur le site de kasparov donc les
remarques de kasparov justement qu'à
sport vous dit que chiron fait des très
bonnes chances dans ce match qu'il
arrive à oublier son passif contre un an
de faux billets sont passés voilà j'ai
fait ce que je fais une mini rubrique de
josé sur les deux questions pour
stéphane on n'a plus le temps joue aussi
de la nation at il ajouté
favori pour le match mais shirov
qu'est-ce que je suis enfin de gagner à
bordeaux le grand prix de bordeaux subit
le sénat donc nous on a une petite
alors disons qu'on a mais bon on aime
bien nous aussi donc en fait bon mais
shirov quand même aller et qu'est-ce que
je te coupe les cheveux je me couche je
cire organes
voilà d'accord d'accord donc vous le
savez c'est la demande qui gagne et bien
stéphane devra attendre l'année d'après
voilà à couper l'accès des secours que
chi entier y voit la diagonale donc on
vous donne rendez vous vendredi prochain
vendredi prochaine pour commenter cette
finale ne sera ou trois partis au bout
de deux ou trois parties mais je crois
que ces deux partis puisqu'ils jouent
jeudi et vendredi ont jugé décevante de
partir donc deux parties ou fera mine
rendez vous après on part en vacances
et oui même la taylor séquence forcé à
noter est évident on est venu faire le
27 ne peut pas donc rendez vous en
janvier après pour la suite mais
vendredi prochain voilà pour le début de
cette finale d'exception merlin